you had Andy get up and come over here
and sit on this side with me on my lap
yeah I liked it I really liked it and
yeah I better but I but I'm just saying
that you know was it you broke it up a
little bit you know it was the same way
we've been doing you didn't like it did
you I was okay I mean you know his legs
are kind of boney
she's super comfortable why don't you
come over here you want me on that side
when you come up oh I've got an idea
yeah why don't we do a manwich holding
down : down face up me on top of you and
you on top of me Oh
[Applause]
you've got suit on I know I know
look at that we're ready to go to have a
lot of sexy time if you lay down man lay
down here face down yeah fight no you no
no no face up you go interview me you've
got or either leave me view you
comfortable then me on top you'd write
right
[Music]
[Applause]
it's good now wait you want me to
interview you about your project yeah
ask me about Derek okay Ricky well this
is I wish you could see there anyway to
see what I see amazing Ricky's head here
and Andy peering over him like we're
quiet for just about five seconds
someone will turn on in that time and
they just see this and they won't know
what's going on so
so everywhere so Derek maybe Derek you
have you been drinking no no get over
here and you gotta get down here and you
have to see the madness I'm seeing Derek
this is a lovely character that you play
there's a lot of humor in the show but
this also it's a lot of and it's on
Netflix and it's screaming
[Applause]
the special is available now on Netflix
and I would say what you were plugging
was really serious I'll tell you what
he's plugging I'm shutting it down to
one hour Darryl oh gods now streaming on
[Applause]
you